the second installment of the Divergent
franchise has more action than ever it's
an exciting action-packed film with
great performances with their expansive
new budget fresh characters stepping
onto the scene and the insane amount of
stunt sequences we've got a lot to talk
about when it comes to what brought it
all together number one and jumping back
into character after the major success
of the first film the actors definitely
felt the pressure coming back for the
second installment there is there's that
sense of if you're gonna do a second
movie you want to just raise the stakes
even higher and you want to take it to
that next level and the cast actually
found it to be a challenge coming back
because they were shooting other
projects during the break as well as
everything from the location to the
director is different from the first
film number two we're talking tons and
tons of running though Shailene did have
some hard-working stunt doubles she
really wanted to do as many stunts as
she could you kind of want to do as many
sense as you're allowed and then
Insurance steps in and it's like no
you're not doing that she gets a major
thrill from the fact that she gets to do
dangerous things like jumping out of a
plane for instance but knowing that her
parachute is going to come out no matter
what number three we love a dangerous
train jump I feel they might why me and
not be like a superhero proper you know
like but they were just like no just
jump unlike the first film where there
was a train being pulled by a cable
there wasn't an actual train in this
scene Theo's jump though is 100 real it
was just all right Theo jump from there
to there make a believable action
number four you know what scene we're
talking about here one of shailene's
favorite stunts to be a part of was the
sequence where Tris is chasing the house
that day there were at least four stunt
doubles for her can you imagine five
Tris look-alikes all wearing the same
outfit walking around set in an
interview with Canton rep Shailene talks
about her experience with that scene
there's one moment where the house is
tilted at almost a 90 degree angle and
that felt pretty badass I knew if I
didn't grab the pole I wasn't gonna get
hurt but I would be dangling in the air
and having a crazy Bad Wedgie so that
was fun number five naturally there are
gonna be some wardrobe malfunctions we
didn't think it was possible to rip that
many pairs of pants according to Jai
Courtney the costumes and Insurgent were
great if you were standing still but
once you start running through the
Jungle the pants ripping was kind of
inevitable it was just people the team
of people feverishly stitching by crotch
number six how could we not be impressed
by this set though it seems like just
another day at the office Shailene was
completely taken aback by the incredible
attention to detail they put into it
something that was so novel to my eyes
and to my experience that she Compares
it to looking at the World of Harry
Potter I felt I could really surrender
myself into the story of what Insurgent
was
number seven we love to see it Shailene
Woodley loves working with her usual
cast and crew there's a big sense of
comfort around that but there was
definitely some Newfound excitement when
welcoming Naomi Watts on to set their
gifts their Artistry is going to bring
something different out in you that
maybe somebody else hasn't brought out
in you number eight we're big fans of
any fashion statement Shailene Woodley
wants to make right before shooting
Insurgent Shailene starred as Hazel In A
Fault In Our Stars and had her hair cut
short for the role to save herself time
in the makeup chair she decided that was
the look she wanted to stick with for
insurgent and not go through the trouble
of wearing a wig every day it also helps
that in the novel Tris does cut her hair
to about chin length hey Trish I really
like your hair by the way did you try to
cut it all short and weird number nine
it can be difficult when you're hanging
from a high wire when you're filming it
it's easy to sort of forget about the
stakes when trying to stay in character
Shailene Woodley and Theo James had to
actively think about how high the stakes
were in the film and do their best to
depict it in every scene you're holding
a gun you're pretending to be shooting
but you're not actually shooting and no
one's actually getting hurt it was
important for them to remind themselves
and each other to always be raising the
stakes and make it feel really really
important and and life-threatening
number 10. Ansel Elgort has a beautiful
explanation behind it so we all know as
far as the back go in this franchise
Caleb isn't exactly top of the list and
I wanted to make sure it'd make a
conscious decision and be specific with
that he really wanted to be true to who
his character was in his decision to
leave Tris and four behind not everyone
is a superhero not everyone's an action
hero I think Caleb represents the
intellectual to back up ansel's decision
regarding his character there was some
additional footage shot on the train
when Tris gets herself and everyone else
into an almost fatal fight at that point
Caleb has an opportunity to step in and
help her but he doesn't we then showed
him making the decision not to he even
reluctantly has to defend himself
against an attacker so as far as Caleb
goes it's not strictly just his physical
capabilities it's more about his
internal struggle behind it he knows
he's not cut out for this lifestyle so
he decides to leave
number 11. there's a ton of new elements
for our Divergent heroes in this one
when discussing the direction of the
characters it seems evident that in the
first film The most important thing was
to set up who they were now coming into
Insurgent everyone was able to expand a
little more and create a much more
rounded character and this one because
the problems that her interests are
having you see a darker side of her it's
fun for me to play that number 12. as we
mentioned before there was a new
director on Insurgent Neil Berger
directed Divergent so to have him
replaced with Robert shenka was a
totally fresh experience for everyone
involved when Shailene first found out
Neil wasn't going to be directing she
was a little concerned but overall it
ended up being a wonderful experience
and a collaborative one at that Shailene
opened up to Canton rep about her time
working with Robert he doesn't have an
ego he's very open to collaboration and
he's into hearing what you have to say
and taking your opinions into account
that was such a blessing he showed up
every day with a smile on his face and
uh let's do this attitude number 13.
definitely not metaphorically when
talking about the first film director
Neil Burger really focused on building
the world for the audience now for
Insurgent because everything really is
crumbling the whole purpose of the movie
was to tear that world down the
Divergence can sort of come out and
identify themselves and can actually
find a place in Society number 14
definitely a game changer we had a bit
more money so that always helped when
Divergent was first brought to life the
book was only a manuscript so obviously
they didn't have as much money to fund
it but as we mentioned earlier Divergent
did really really well the books alone
were starting to sell up to 30 million
copies so then there was a direct
correlation in budget with their
Newfound budget increase they they were
able to do all of the incredible action
sequences we got the pleasure of seeing
an Insurgent number 15 also known as the
secret title of insurgent because of how
successful Divergent was literally
grossing over 288 million dollars
worldwide there was a lot of hype for
its successor in an attempt to keep
things under wraps and prevent spoilers
from surfacing online the working title
while filming was changed to Mineral
we've got incredible action a dedicated
cast brimming with chemistry a new and
improved budget and a ton of fresh faces
what was your favorite moment from
Insurgent let us know in the comments
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things
foreign